that's Aquaman doing in aqua dance yep
there's Aquaman star Jason Momoa taking
off his coat at the film's LA premiere
joining his pals and his kids on the
blue carpet for a traditional Hakka
dance respect to beginning of the god of
water and then it's about finding your
your mana so where does it come from
from your ancestors from you people and
then I respect would come up to at the
end for all my Modi and she came to help
me but it's a very intimate dance about
where we find our mana from our
ancestors from our mind about your
spirit from my heart when did you teach
your kids that because they were right
in there they didn't learn right now
they've got a they've done a lot of
Hawkins I pasted in when I was little
too so they knew it and we just added
two together so there he had it down not
King
we've always had a key now I need
something more
what could be greater than I can
a hero so you're gonna get to see the
movie tonight with the kids you told me
is what you've been waiting for the
first time
superb oh yeah I asked them how excited
were they to see dad's movie they're
like excited a little nervous but I'm
very excited okay SNL we talked all
about it the highest-rated show of the
season so far
yes sir how about that awesome that was
the time of my life I loved it I loved
and I had a great his time got us
thinking the Oscars need a host what do
you think good I would love to go yep
we saw them from the photo of you and
Linney with the matching rings I love it
whose idea was that
oh I did I had a made my friend my
friend and uh he made this bone ring
since I wanted to get one the lighting
he liked it so I wanted him babbling
symbolism of just family and a blended
meal
[Music]